hi and welcome to the vlog so that's
been a bit crazy recently and let's just
talk it out shall we
so to start off with earlier this month
I went off to Oxford if those of you who
are new here might not know I did my
undergraduate and Peter's College and
I've been making videos for them and
their access work ever since I've left
so I was doing a shooting trip to do
some interviews with some members of the
student population including one of the
hit rivers Museum which is really fun
and also interviewing the new schools
liaison officers lovely lady I also did
an interview with the first female
Bishop in the Church of England Libby
Lane who was a who is a graduate of the
college just on the fly I didn't really
know anything I was making these
questions as I went and it was a massive
adrenaline rush I got to say basically I
was I was it was an alumni event because
the college is presenting her with this
is our fellowship and I just sorta went
up to an our site okay we just get a few
questions as if I've been doing it all
my life and it came out okay that videos
gonna be coming out on the San Peters
channel very soon also I uh I went to an
event in London so the college was
launching a campaign to raise money
because we were very new and very poor
college and I was approached by a lady
at the the event in London who was a
lecturer at Warwick uni as it turns out
she's been using my videos as part of
her University course on digital
communication and I've been like a
teaching resource in like a case theory
of how to tell a story digitally so I'm
being studied at Warwick uni which is
crazy because I applied to study at
Warwick uni I didn't ever think I would
be studied there so that was a lot
station and also well as an Oxford I had
the opportunity to meet up with Sally
LePage so if you don't know who's Sally
is she is a Oxford based science
youtuber she's doing a PhD in biology
there but she's been working recently
with people over at General Electric and
doing a whole bunch of cool videos with
them so link to her channel there's
something on the screen I haven't
decided yet I don't know if you know
this but when you make vlogs this stuff
this doesn't like appear up here I have
to put it in in post or whatever future
Simon decided to put in flip back and go
and check out our channel because she's
really cool and we were talking in the
San John's MCR until literally 2:00 in
the morning about
- it was really nice to meet you sadly
if you're watching this I then had a few
days to catch my breath here in x2 and
before I knew it I was flying off to
Jersey so I flew to Jersey to work with
a fantastic organization called Daryl
and they are an international
conservation charity and I made a video
about them for the project for awesome
and they saw that video and asked if I'd
like to come and work with them to make
some videos which I instantly went yes
yes yes please
so I we went and filmed for a couple of
days in the site in Jersey which is what
used to be Jersey zoo and I got to work
with some phenomenal species and we're
making three videos for their YouTube
channel which are going to focus on the
road recruit back to the angry land
racer and the pipe tamron which are
three of their conservation milestone
campaigns really but I also got to
interview some really amazing people
like the head of mammals head of
herpetology and their communications
manager Rick incidentally if you're
watching this thank you so much for
setting everything up and arranging
everything and it was a little bit
stressful but my god I had the best time
and I cannot wait to get these videos
out there
I got peed on I got pooed on I got
electrocuted and I had the best two or
three days of my life it was amazing so
in addition to these videos for the
dural youtube channel there's gonna be
some on this channel I've logged the
entire time and those are becoming out
quite soon I think I've slated them for
release early July the vlogs and then
also a series of feature videos if you
like we're going to ask some lot of big
questions like why deserts that exists
why animals going extinct and why should
we save them from extinction and they're
gonna be coming out a little bit after
I've got a schedule worked out on my
laptop and there's just there's so many
videos coming out soon it's a little bit
crazy but the footage I got from Dahl I
am so so happy with I mean I actually
got to go in with the tamarins and be
used as a climbing frame I got to go in
with these fruit bats it was just so
fantastic I cannot wait to show you guys
so at the moment at the present time I
am here in Exeter for another couple of
days and then I fly off to Germany with
chapel tour with the University Chapel
Choir we're going to Stuttgart
ravensberg and doing a whole bunch of
concerts and stuff and cathedrals which
is going to be really really fun but it
will a mean that I will have been away
from xterm or this month when I watched
in here but there will be a vlog coming
out about that which is gonna be like
some monster 20 minute thing it can be
so much fun and hopefully I can capture
some of that on camera now you might
wonder especially feel my supervisor I'm
watching this
how on earth my PhD is going given that
all this is going on and the answer is
actually surprisingly well being away
from here so much allow me to really
take a step back and focus on the
question I say to myself what am I
actually trying to do with this PhD
rather than just thinking old you know
based on the supervisor meeting we're
gonna do this and then this and then
this you actually get to sit back and
think about why you're doing this in the
first place and what questions
specifically you're trying to answer so
I've now got a much more rounded idea of
what my thesis is gonna be about which I
think is going to be basically about
testing an existing idea in the field
which is which has been around for a few
decades applying it to this relatively
new phenomena which we observe which is
this coupling of the strategy and the
troposphere if you don't know what my
PhD is about by the way check out this
link I did a pizza video explaining what
it was all about in 60 seconds and also
assess our comparing that original
hypothesis to a new hypothesis which my
supervisor has been working on for a
while and I've been doing the math about
four and basically comparing predictions
from one hypothesis and the other and
see how they perform and how useful they
are so I was actually able when I was at
Doral to sit down on my laptop quite a
few hours and just work the stuff out
and write out a an action plan and it
felt incredibly good to do that so I
feel really quite organized at the
moment I thought I spent all of today
really going at it
sorting through all of my program
sorting through all my data making sure
everything is categorized and it now
feels like I've taken a step back looked
at everything from a bird's eye view and
then I can zero in on exactly what I
need to do now so I'm actually really
confident about how the phd's going
having said that I have got to present
in a conference and start of July so I
might not be so confident just before
then but yeah so I've mentioned already
that there were like a million and one
different videos coming out we've got
the Darryl vlogs we've got the double
feature videos we've got chapel tour
we've got the conference vlog there's
also gonna be the series on the strategy
coming out I'm really sorry that that
hasn't come out sooner but basically I
wasn't ready to do it I'd have done it
but it woulda been a rush job and I
you guys deserve better than that and I
wanted to do better than that so I
postpone that for a few weeks if my
memory serves correctly I think that's
coming out June slash July when I want
to get back from chapel tour but I'd
have to look at the schedule like
literally I've now got to the point
where a schedule out videos I think
until the start of September because I
listen to all of that I've been writing
a series recently on the more meta
aspects of YouTube so talking about how
you construct a video how you produce it
to get a certain the cinema time is news
on sin and looking at that also looking
at the character that youtubers portray
in their vlogs there's a something that
Sally and I talked about an awful lot
actually I've got me thinking about how
the person you see a video blogger that
you watch interviews is not them it is a
representation of them that they choose
and I find out really interesting topic
and I think it's worth exploring in a
video so there's give me a short series
on that coming out what else there will
be more ax Kong coming I haven't had a
chance to film it I know that not that
many people watch it if you don't watch
it don't feel bad because it's not
everybody's cup of tea but I thought it
would be fun to try and do a video play
a video game play through on this
channel so they will be coming out I've
got to record them now before I head off
to Germany but I will try and get some
coming out whilst I'm away so you don't
have a heaven forbid you have a week
where you don't get a video from me
and then I think that's about as far
forward as I thought I am also thinking
of doing a short series on some of the
concepts of my PhD basically really for
me so I can take these quite abstract
concepts like a licen palm flux and
potential vorticity and things which are
very very mathematical and abstract and
actually see if I can communicate them
to an audience that doesn't have a
Pierre degree in physics you know
because I'm assuming that most of you
who are watching this video either
starting your degrees you know or
partially through your degrees which
probably aren't going to be in exactly
my field all your sixth formers all your
GCSE students so it'd be really
challenging for me to try and take these
really out there concepts and
communicate them so that might be
happening there'll be short videos we'll
see really this summer's gonna be
interesting because I really got a I got
a fire under my ass basically to to
really crack on with a PhD which I've
lit myself and I'm really keen to get on
with it I've got an awful lot that I
want to do
at the same time I've also got a lot of
video stuff already planned I've got a
lot of stuff which I'm gonna edit for
other people like some Peters like
federal yeah it's gonna be interesting
to see if I can squeeze in any more
because I'm still at this interesting
juncture right where I'm doing a PhD but
I'm also doing a lot of video work and
we're getting to the point where this
channel is starting to be relatively
serious I mean I had a month at the past
month I got a hundred thousand views and
that a lot of that had to do with the
series on getting ready for exams and
also some traffic from the series on
applying to Oxbridge which incidentally
I hope you found useful if you did
please comment down below because I'm
sort of using that as a testbed really
for future educational series I want to
use that format and how I produce those
so feedback on that is very very much
appreciated but yeah we're getting to
this point where this channel is now
starting to be kind of serious it's not
just me talking in a room I'm also doing
a trying to do more serious content and
more educational content and a broader
spectrum so I can't do that to a
professional standard as a full-time job
and do my PhD and do the singing and do
all the other things I do in my life you
know something's gonna have to give it
some point and at the end of the day
it's probably gonna be YouTube which has
to suffer slightly I'm still here
putting out content hopefully every week
but it's not going to be like rocket
jump or blue zephyros or the slow mo
guys it's not going to be basically my
full-time job for at least the
foreseeable future so that's it from me
in this video the next thing will
because that will be coming out on this
channel I think will be a dural vlog
there isn't going to be video next week
unless I can get ex-con recorded and
like put out but I really hope you're
enjoying all the content that I'm
putting out because I really do enjoy
making it for you I really do it is
stressful and it's tough but trying to
get stuff as professional as I can and
know it and and hearing about from you
guys in the comments that you're
enjoying it or you're not enjoying it is
is really gratifying it's it's really
really great I love doing this oh and
before we go I really hope everyone's
exams went ok if they're still going on
good luck leave down in the comments
your your stories about how exams went
because judging by Twitter there was
some horror stories coming out of GCSEs
and a-levels so
yeah hope you're okay a good luck if you
haven't finished and I'll be seeing you
when I get back from Germany so well no
I'll be seeing you from Jersey when I
get back from Germany in a week's time
but that event that you're going to be
seeing has already happened Internet